parti pour ces élèves c'est madame
claire après un an de suppléance
elle a sa propre classe de 3e et 4e
année dans une école de heureusement
vraiment formidable j'ai retrouvé ma
stabilité d'emploi que j'avais que
j'avais quitté en france oblige end mais
peut ester malgré sa formation et son
expérience en france elle doit faire
certains cours à l'université pour
devenir enseignante qualifié au québec
si on est très très aidée par les
collègues par la direction on est
vraiment épaules et on avait ce projet
là depuis longtemps de partir à
l'étranger au moins un an ou deux
bonjour tout le monde
c'est en rencontrant les commissions
scolaires à paris en juin dernier que
camille mauls à s'est retrouvé à
montréal à la fin ou parce que j'aimais
avec la csmv c'est qu'elle me propose un
poste dans une école
donc j'avais pas besoin de de faire
trois ou quatre écoles ce qui fait que
je suis suppléante issia pas de gérer la
joie alors qu'on cherche plus de 200
suppliant chaque jour à la commission
scolaire marguerite bourgeoys la venue
de camille est une bénédiction
si une pénurie mais on est vraiment en
situation d'urgence juste pour le mode
ou l'année prochaine c'est au dessus de
300 enseignants peu près qu'on va avoir
besoin là comme sûre scolaire marguerite
bourgeoys
le ministère de l'éducation va
chapeauter une troisième mission de
recrutement en france à la fin du mois
ça vaut la peine parce qu'il faut
combler ces postes la mission à paris la
dernière mission qu'on a fait au moins 2
juin celle de toulouse de permis et
d'avoir à peu près 61 ans enseignant
pour la rentrée prochaine
mais le processus s'est ralentie au
niveau de l'immigration parce que
l'enseignement primaire et secondaire ne
se retrouve pas sur la liste des
professions en pénurie
la problématique actuellement ses quais
les personnes qui ont été recrutées dans
une démission ne peuvent pas arriver
parce qu'ils n'ont pas tous les papiers
la commission scolaire de montréal s'est
adressée au ministre de l'éducation pour
qu'il fasse pression sur ses homologues
de l'immigration et de l'emploi vous
avez l'intention vraiment le coup de
coeur et elle est prête à partager son
expérience avec les prochains
enseignants qui poseront leurs valises
au québec ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal